Assalamu alaykum. I really want to thank
Walk forever for partnering with
Abdullah in this absolutely amazing very
very important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. Restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs. People have lost hands and uh
legs, some above the knee, some below
the knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example.
Ash Ahmed, mashallah, he's one of the so
many whom we've been able to assist with
your partnership. So, may Allah reward
you and grant you goodness and may Allah
almighty continue to use all of us to do
this good work.
[Music]
Where are you from? Where are you from?
Turkey.
Really? Uh, Mr. Mson.
Yeah. I don't like Islam. Why not? I
think it's very sexist and misogynistic.
What parts? And the fact that like women
have to cover up. I need to cover up. I
mean I think it objectifies women you
know I have to cover up my like I cannot
wear this and I think by covering myself
I'm essentially sexualizing my body
because I say that okay I have to cover
up because men will look at me men can
rape me I'm just going to cover up why
can't we why can't we teach men to be
decent so the the Quran if you look into
the Quran sister I came to I'm from
Turkey as well I'm from so I came to
Islam I only believed in God I didn't
have any religion but if you think about
it the biggest sexual objectifications
happened to the western Let me tell you
why. Because for example, in the Quran,
Allah tells me that as a man, I have to
lower my gaze. Meaning I shouldn't be
looking at women. Doesn't matter how
they dress. In the beginning, then why
are you looking at me? Because out of
respect. Because I'm looking at you,
speaking to you. If I spoke to you like
this, you'll find it rude. If I look at
you, you say to me, why you looking at
me? I can't win. So usually I should
lower my gaze. But even if I do it, you
will say, oh, why are you not looking at
me? Am I not a human? Proves my point
that Islam is medieval. Okay. Okay. So,
sister, if I look this way, you would
say to me, you don't treat me as a
human. If I look at you, you say to me,
why you looking at me? What do I do? I'm
not going to say about why you're
looking at me. Your book says that you
should lower your gaze, but you're when
you're talking to me, you're not
lowering your gaze. Okay. So, what I'm
saying is usually the reason why I'm not
doing that is because if I done that,
you will find it uh rude when it's not.
First my point that Islam is medieval.
So, do you prefer a do you prefer me to
sexually objectify you or not? I don't
want you to sexually objectify me. Good.
So what I'm saying is as a man I am
created to have um attraction to the
opposite gender. So do I look at them or
not look at them? What's better? Do you
think as a man should I look at women or
not look at women? Well, you don't
sexualize women. Just treat me as like a
colleague.
No no no like while while lowering your
gaze. No no one sexist. I'm seeing to
you look do you know when I'm walking do
you think as a man I should be looking
around or just not look around? You look
at where you want to look. But a minute
ago you just said I shouldn't look. I'm
saying is your book said that you
shouldn't if your book says that you
should lower your gaze. Exactly. That's
what your book says. But you're looking
at me. Are you going to follow but I'm
talking to you. So when when we're
talking about lowering the gays, it's
also an understanding. It doesn't mean
that when I'm talking to the opposite
gender, I do this not. It says that if
you have a desire in you or whatever,
etc. I'm talking to you in a respectful
manner and that's why I'm talking to
you. But what I'm saying is lowering the
gaze applies to however a woman is
dressed. It doesn't matter if she wears
a bikini. Even if a woman covers her
face, I should lower my gaze. So because
I'm having a dialogue with you, I'm
trying to tell you about Islam. I have
to communicate with and look at you. But
obviously I'm not, you don't see me
looking elsewhere. So now I'm saying the
sexual objectification of women is done
to the western woman. Well, you know
why? Because why do women wear makeup?
Because I like looking pretty. Okay. Why
do you like looking pretty? Because I
feel good. You So are you okay? Do you
choose to look pretty or are you told to
look pretty? Why are you maintaining
your beard? Who are you? I'm told to Who
are you trying to impress? God. Who are
you trying to impress? I'm trying to
impress God. I'm trying to by by looking
beautiful. Yes. Okay. Look, I I look my
point is this. Have you read a book
called Beauty Sick? Huh? It's called the
beauty sick. It's written by a
non-Muslim author. It talks about the
sexual objectification of women. How
women starve theirelves to look the
perfect way. How they go and sleep
around with men to get um validation.
Now, why is the western woman doing
this? And why is there so many women
coming to Islam? Not the okay the
average western woman does not sleep
around. That's a lie that Muslims put
forward. So So they don't So okay, how
do you know how many sexual partners a
western woman has in her lifestyle in in
a lifetime? Anywhere from 10 to 15.
Um do you think that's good or bad for a
woman? I think it's really bad for a
woman. Okay. Well, good thing that
you're not a woman. No, no, no. But I'm
seeing sister is that as Islam says you
are a woman have so much to offer than
your beauty. Islam says you're a human
being. You have so much more to offer
the world. You should not be judged by
your beauty. So the western woman does
what? And the western system does what?
You have a billboard. There's a
chocolate bar and there's a naked woman.
What's the woman got to do with a
chocolate bar? Have I ever said that I
support that? I never said that. You
said Islam is misogynist. Islam is
misogynistic because you have to cover
from head to toe everywhere. So how's
that misogynistic? Because you're
essentially sexualizing your body. You
accept that. The reason why I'm covering
my arm is because men can get horny from
it. There's nowhere in Islam that says
that you should cover up cuz men get
horny. Why can't you then why can't you
show your beautiful arms? Let me tell
you why. Because Allah tells us that for
a weakness for a man is that he likes to
look. A woman likes to look beautiful.
So it's a test for me to lower my gaze
and it's a test for a woman to cover her
beauty. Her beauty is for who? For her
for her husband. Now, okay. So what I'm
saying, look, if you are you married or
you have someone in your life? I'm not
married. Okay. So if you had someone in
your life, he'll be jealous over you. He
might come and say look what I don't
like men looking at you. A man has this
natural inclination to be protective
over his woman. Is that a bad thing?
What type of medieval atrocity is this?
So medieval atrocity is that for
example, would you like a man that cares
about you doesn't care about you? Why is
my husband controlling me? One second.
Okay. Why can I wear this dress? Okay.
No. No. One second. If your husband was
doing something that you didn't like him
to do, is is that you're controlling
him? No. But like I want to wear what I
want. I want to be able to wear this
dress. Do you think this dress is
indecent? It depends what you depend
what is indecent. Do you want your
husband to have female friends? Well,
surely my boyfriend wouldn't want me to
dress up like a ninja like cover from
the top. It's better. Well, it's to me
there's nothing wrong with that. What's
wrong with that? Well, it's wrong for my
boyfriend. He wouldn't like it. I
wouldn't want it. Would you want your
boyfriend to have female friends that he
hangs around with children around? I
don't mind. I have guy friends. My best
friend is a guy. Exactly. So, this is
what we say. This why you need Islam.
You know why? Because there was a study
done and research has showed that men
and women cannot be friends.
Well, shame. He is Hindu and he's my
best friend. Nothing so far happened.
Why can I be Call him now. Call him now
and say to him you're interested in him.
See what he says.
Call him now. Say to him you you have
feelings for him. But be genuine and see
what he says.
Call him. Just say to him. Say, "You
know what? I've been thinking about
camera." Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's
nice. Just call him and say to him, "I
have I have I have feelings for you."
See what he says. Well, this is
something private. Why should I say this
on camera? I promise you he will say you
know what I say to oh my gosh I've been
waiting for this all my life I'm a man I
know who man how men operate you can't
you can't generalize you can't I'll tell
you every single man let me tell you
something I used let me tell yeah
exactly but you can't generalize every
single man sister Islam has come to
honor you yeah you might have a wrong
perception because of Turkey I know what
what happens in Turkey yeah what happens
in Turkey you know with the what happens
and then look you know you know there's
yeah what do you think about that what
happens no no I'm saying because of that
don't put a label on everybody like I
come from where you come We're from the
same country. Yeah. We're from the same
country. But don't put everyone in the
same category. Yeah. Cuz what you're
doing now is you say Islam is
misogynistic. Islam is you have you
don't even know the principles of Islam.
Islam. Why do I cover myself up? Why do
I cover myself? I have to cover myself
from my naval to my knee. When I go when
I go swimming, I can't go topless. I
know. But why should I cover my breasts
and my forearms? What's wrong with that?
Let me tell you something, sister. Yeah.
Let me tell you why we cover up or why I
grow the beard or why we do what we do.
Yeah. Do you accept God exists? Do you
believe in a god? I can't say anything
about that. Like, do you have any belief
or no belief? I mean, I'm an atheist.
Okay. So, I can prove God exists. Let's
start with God. Then everything will
make sense. Okay. Look, what's your
name, sister? Prefer not to say my name.
Can I can I call you uh Finn? Sister.
I'll call you sister. Okay, sister. So,
that's fine. So, let me make it very
simple for you. Okay. You would agree
that everything that we look at around
here has a purpose. From the TV to the
buildings to my watch to your trainers
to your dress to your bag. Everything
has a purpose. Yeah. Yeah. Good. Okay.
Now, the bag that you're wearing, does
it have a designer?
Oh my god. Yes. What happened? Oh my
god. I haven't finished my sentence.
Okay. It has a designer. Does he have a
purpose? Okay. Does it have a specific
pattern? A pattern? Yes. Okay. Good.
Have you seen the designer?
Exist somewhere. Yes. No. But have you
seen him? No, I haven't. Okay. Do you?
Except he exists. Oh, wait a minute. So,
it's like it's like Wi-Fi, right? Like
no Wi-Fi we can't see. We can't see
Wi-Fi. But Wi-Fi exists. So it's like
God is like that as well, right? No, but
you you didn't say I don't believe in
God cuz I don't see. I'm making an
argument from design. So I'm saying have
you seen the design of your bag? No, I
haven't. Okay. Do you accept he exists?
Yeah, because he designed the bag. Good.
Perfect. No, that's that's I agree with
you. I mean, I am with you. Okay, good.
Are you more complex in design? Is your
eye more complex in design or your bag?
Well, you can't prove or disprove that
God exists. It's something emotional.
You made an argument. I mean, I I I I
have friends who believe in it's
something emotional. It's something I
don't judge that. I know. Let me hear.
You cannot turn me to a theist. I I'm
not here to do nothing. I'm having a
rational argument discussing this. And
why are we discussing this? Because I'm
saying is your eye more complex in
design or your bag? My eye. Good.
Therefore, if the argument follows, your
bag has a design. You haven't seen it.
It has a purpose. It has a pattern. Your
eye has a function. It has a purpose. He
has a pattern. And it's designed. Your
eye is made out of DNA. DNA has
information. Information requires
intelligence. So that intelligence is
what? How? Okay. If God exists, how do
they know that Islam is his religion?
But not Judaism, but not Christianity.
But not But we haven't come to religion
yet. I'm just saying God. Does God
exist? You said to me you're an atheist.
I don't care if God exists or not.
What's How is that relevant to the
argument? Let me tell you why, sister.
Because let me tell you why I'm making
this argument and it relates to the
hijab and my beard and everything else.
If God exists and he's the one who
created you, he's the one that makes
your heartbeat. He's the one that feeds
you, looks after you. He's given you
this eye, this heart, and this body.
Meaning, mate, mate, mate, mate, I think
you're going on a tangent. We were
talking about the sexual sex sexual
sexualization of relation back to the
sister. Look, I'm saying if God exists,
if God says to me, if God exists, why
does why doesn't he if God says to me
how jump? I say how high because he's
the one who created me. He owns this
earth and he owns me me. So he tells me
what to do. I don't tell him what to do.
Do you get the point? So when you come
and say why hijab, why your beard, why
this, why that, it all goes back to that
because you follow authority. You are
you telling me you don't have a
religion? I don't. Can I ask you a
question? Why do you dress up like this?
And I'm not talking in a sexual I'm not
saying that this dress. No, you don't.
You have been taught this. One second.
My mom bought this dress. No, I'm not
talking about the dress. The dress might
look pretty. You're not understanding my
point. You have been watching and
affected by the western system to dress
up like this. What's wrong with western
system? Thank you. That's my point.
What's wrong with the western system of
the philosopher John Stewart Mill Adam
Smith? What's wrong with them? What's
wrong about them? They they believe the
two gods of you live here. If you hate
the western world, why did you move
here? Why aren't you back in Turkey? You
said I have to hate it. Just because I'm
challenging the views doesn't mean I
hate it. Are you telling me? Okay.
You're saying basically you're here, you
shut up, you don't talk. I'm challenging
your world. Your world view I'm
challenging. I'm saying the way you
dress, how you dress is not cuz you
choose to. It's because you're
programmed to. No, I choose to. Sister,
can I ask a question? I'm programmed.
You are programmed to to grow a beard if
you in a hurry. By the way, okay, before
you're in a hurry, just a quick
question. Okay, I'm asking you a simple
question. Who's told you that dressing
like this is okay? And I'm not talking
in a sexual way. I'm just saying once
told you to wake up and say, you know
what, I'm going to put this dress on
rather than wearing something long or
something shorter or a bikini. Why this
dress? Well, I picked a longer dress
because today is a bit is a bit chilly.
Perfect. So, where the weather plays
role? What else? Yeah, I got lunch with
my dad's friends. Good. Perfect. So, for
something nice for occasion. So, what
I'm saying is this sister, the only
difference between me and you or a
Muslim woman and you is the following.
You are affected by the movies you
watch, Netflix, Instagram, social media,
peer pressure and opposite gender. Peer
pressure. So are you telling me one
second sister are you telling me you
wake up and say I'm going to dress like
this because of no influence. Everyone
is influenced by something somehow. So
you can't come and say to me I made my
decision to wear this dress today or
tomorrow wear a bikini or a miniscuit or
a long dress or whatever it is. You are
influenced by something that makes the
decision factor for you. You are
influenced. You can't you cannot tell me
you're not. You cannot tell me you're
not. You are influenced. I am influenced
people. I agree. I'm influenced by the
one that created me. You are influenced
by society. Yeah, but I don't believe in
God. I know, but that's why I try to put
influenced by the society. Let me tell
you why. Cuz Allah says to us in the
Quran, have you seen the one who has one
master compared to many masters? You the
fashion changes. Tomorrow they'll come
and say fashion is wearing this. Me God
says to me one commandment for men and
women. It gives me a way of life. I
follow one master. You have to follow
what's the next fashion. Oh, what's my
friends wearing? Oh my gosh, I like that
dress. You are influenced by multiple
people. Let me tell you what's wrong
with that. What they want to wear,
whether they want to wear the hij they
want to wear this. Let women want to
wear the case. If if you are so
feminist, then why are you against a
woman wearing a hijab or a ba? No, I
said I'm not against it. Let you said
why you wearing like a ninja? No, no,
no. I said that let women what they want
to wear, but I believe that in theory it
sexualize women. I know for someone it
empowers them to go out wearing the
hijab or ba. I'm not against it, but I
think that it sexualizes. You know why
is they're in the control of sexuality?
Because they don't want to show men what
they what they uh what they look like.
They are saying talk to me as a as a
human being to my face, not somewhere
else. And you know what? Not only that,
it also protects you from men falling in
love with you the wrong way and breaking
your heart.
I'm a man and there's men behind you. I
can ask them. Let me tell you something.
When you are dressed up in a certain
way, men will come to you and give you
false promises for one thing. What Islam
does sister is protect you as a human
being and your heart and your soul. But
essentialize as woman. Let me tell you
sister. Look, do you know how I met my
wife and I married her? Look, my wife, I
have a protocol in Islam. I can't go on
dates with her, test drive. It doesn't
work like that. She has honor. Which
means what? When I approached her, I
spoke to her father. Why? Because Islam
says Islam protects her heart. Number
one. Number two, she was covered up.
Okay? I'm not saying that women who are
covered up who won't get raped. There
are women who are covered up who get
raped. My argument is not from rape. My
argument is that what does Islam tell
you to follow to protect your heart for
the betterment for your wellbeing and
the wellbeing of the other. So what I'm
saying is this my dear sister Islam has
come to protect your rights and my
rights. So it says there shouldn't be
for example how many women have
psychological issues cuz they meet men
who only want one thing dumb them like a
piece of like they're rubbish. Islam is
saying no you can't go and abuse women
be with them like they're toilet.
They're not toilet for you to go and
have intimacy with them and chuck them
away. Islam says no a woman has rights.
You as a woman have rights. So Islamist
protocols, I had to speak to my wife.
She I had to pay a dowy. Do you know
what a diary is? Yeah. Okay. I had to
pay a dowy. I pay for everything in the
household. Why? Not because I'm
misogynistic and I No. Because I my wife
has rights. When she's pregnant, she's
vulnerable. I have to take care and look
after her. So Islam gives those rights
to her. Why do you not talk about that?
Why do you talk about how Islam protects
her? I'm a full-time bodyguard to her.
If I walk down the road and someone says
something, I will put my life on the
line to protect my protect my wife. And
this is what I'm talking about. God
knows what is best for us. Sister, don't
look at Islam with what goes on in
Turkey. Look, I'm not pro Erdogan or
anyone. Forget them. I'm talking to you
about Islam. This book here, give it a
chance. I was a bit like you 14, 15
years ago. I gave the chance. I said,
"Let me read the scripture. Let me read
for myself." Islam is not misogynistic.
If there's any religion that honors
women to the level Islam, there's female
scholars in Islam. Then why was Aisha a
kid when she got married? Then why not?
Why can men take three wives and I can't
take two husbands? Four wives. Sorry,
four wives, not three. Yeah, I'm I'm
just trying to clarify. Yeah. Okay.
Again, sister, Muslim men in general,
they have one wife, but Islam is a
pragmatic religion. Do you know how many
non-Muslim men have side chicks and
mischief and girlfriends in the
workplace?
I mean,
do you know what they do? Let me tell
you what they do. Look, this is what
Islam says. Islam says if a man, if a
man has the ability, and if you talk
about atheism, evolution in four
minutes, that's fine, sister. In
evolution, it's evolution is what? The
survival of the fittest. In evolution,
polygamy is perfectly fine because it is
procreating. It's the survival. A man
having 20 wives is no problem. In
atheism, you can't have no cap on it
because you know why? Because it's your
tribal. You have to protect yourself.
And me, one man can impregnate 50 women
and then have kids from them. He has an
empire. So evolutionary perspective,
from the atheistic worldview, you can't
have a problem with polygamy. Atheist,
atheists don't have that worldview. No,
no, no. In as an atheist, you believe in
evolution. Correct. Yes. In evolution,
they believe the survival of the
fittest. Mean is spreading your genes.
explain your we're in the 21st century.
Oh, good. I'm saying to you that's one
reason. Islam may be feminist for it
time, but it's not feminist right now.
Islam doesn't need to be feminist. Islam
gives the rights of the woman. Islam
says the greatest inequality is to give
um um sorry I forgot the words. It's
basically a woman um has specific rights
and a man has specific rights. You can't
treat them equally. For example, when a
woman is pregnant, you can't treat that
woman the same. Do you get what I'm
trying to say? She needs to be looked
after. So what I'm saying is Islam gives
rights to protect the woman. You as a
woman, if I was your brother in Islam,
the man who wants to marry you, number
one, he has to be marriage. Number two,
he has to come and speak to me. Number
three, he needs to pay you mah dowry.
That's your security. If he leaves you
and goes, you have security for you and
your kids. Number four, the money that
you make is yours. He cannot touch it.
He has to provide and protect for
everything. And he's your full-time
bodyguard. But isn't that a hard on men?
It doesn't. It is. Let me tell you
something. Let me tell you something.
Let me tell you something. It is hard on
men. But we say if God said it we obey.
We don't come and say no if God said it
I will do my duty. It is hard. Believe
me as men it is very difficult for me to
be the provider and protector. And my
wife look I come and say why is my wife
sitting at home? She can go work. I want
to sit at home. I enjoy it but at the
same time I do it because God told me to
sister. So what I'm saying is Islam has
come. The greatest let me tell you
something. Read this book beauty sick.
Please read it. I really encourage you
sister. Yeah. Islam honors women. The
western system has degraded women to
such a sexual object that they think
wearing.
Are you with him? No, I'm not. Okay.
Yeah. So interesting. Yeah. Can I ask
something? If if then then why is under
Sharia law a man's testimony is equal to
two woman's testimony? Because it
depends. Okay. For example, we know
sexist. But it is if but let's
put it let's dissect it. The reason why
that is because in certain circumstances
women generally they are the
housemakers. They are not involved in
business like the prophet's first wife
Khadijah. She was a business woman but
not every woman is that. So in certain
circumstances for example also women can
be more woman do you agree women are
more emotional than men? Don't tell me
that's misogynistic. That is that's a
that's a biological fact. Women are more
emotional. It's fine. I'm stronger than
you than men. Good. So what it says is
that for example if a murder happens
here two people get shot. Bang bang
bang. As a man I have got instinct of
I'm like I'm going to get involved.
Woman might be like oh my gosh run for
my life. That's natural. Oh, why can't I
remember things? Sorry. Why can't I
remember things? No, no, no. It says,
for example, in certain instances, when
it comes to business, when it comes to
certain instances, for example, if a
murder happened, Yeah. as men, the way
we are created is different for you.
It's But I can see what happens. No, no,
no. I No, sister. If gunshots are heard.
Yes. Okay. You as as a feminine woman,
you would be like, "Oh my gosh,
survival. I want to protect myself." So
much. So, so that I can still see it. I
know. I know. What I'm saying is this is
stuff. In certain circumstances, Allah
says, "Let them have two witnesses."
Certain circumstances. You know why?
Because Aisha, the prophet's wife, he's
talking about, she was one of the
biggest followers of Islam. She didn't
need two witnesses to teach. Do you see
my point? It's incoherent. No, it's in
certain circumstances. What
circumstances? Look, look, sometimes no
in business when business for example,
if a woman is not involved in business
dealings, she needs another woman to
correct that. For example, but how is
that relevant to giving testimony in
court? It is. For example, if I'm doing
a business with my friend here. Yes. And
for example, they need a witness of a
woman. The woman is not involved in
business. She doesn't know anything
about numbers. She might I I'm a law
student. I will be a lawyer. That
specific circumstance. It would be such
a shame if I went to court and they
said, "Nuh-uh. You got to bring one more
witness to support your witness."
Because you know why there was a lawyer,
sister? There was a wetness of a a a
woman. Her testimony was enough on her
own when she talked about who she um
suckled. They didn't say, "Oh, you are a
woman." In certain circumstances, Islam
is pragmatic. It deals with the reality
of the world. Okay? So, for example, did
we have female soldiers in Islam? Yes.
But rare instances, we're talking about
generally.
It's a general thing. It's not. But then
why do you generalize like that? Two
women equal to one man. No. No. No. You
said that it was I said generally it is
woman's witness is equal. But in
specific situations, it is not. And
that's pragmatic.
M. Yes. Are you friends? Are are you
friends? Yeah. I mean, yeah, he's like a
When is his birthday? I have no idea
exactly. What's your friend? No, I don't
I don't like that. Man don't remember.
You don't know his birthday. You don't
remember. Sometimes I forget. Sometimes
I forget about my children's birthday.
Yeah. Exactly.
We don't say her birthday. Are you guys
friends? You don't you don't remember
your birthday. It's like my teacher. No,
I don't know his birthday. I'll be
honest with you. Sometimes I forget my
daughter's birthday. My wife tells me
men have men had bad memory. That's what
I'm saying. Men have better memory. We
keep the receipts of everything. No,
that's what I'm saying. For example, in
a court, a Sharia court, it might be
that a man who has bad memory is fully
rejected and a woman who has good memory
is accepted. Yeah. But but but by
default by default you say two women
equal to one man by default. No no no I
no I said to you sister in specific
situations generally for example I gave
you the instances I told you in certain
generally it's accepted business. Yes.
Because women are the house. My cousin
does consulting. Well she need another
my cousin does consulting. She's a
female. Does she need does she That's
what I'm saying. If she is if she knows
in that specific instance that it will
change. I'm talking about generally
women's testimony is same but in certain
circumstances that's what I don't like
about Islam. You generalize everything.
Well, you no we don't. You generalize.
You just generalize it. You just said
it. You generalized it. I said generally
a woman's testimony. Generally means
generalized. Sist a woman's testimony is
the same as a man generally. Generally.
But do you not accept that? Yes. Yes.
I'm saying in certain circumstances it's
not. circumstances as in what it
changes. I gave you the example, sister.
You want to go over it again? Why? Why
can it never be two men equal to one?
Well, woman, why? No, no, sister. I've
already explained to you. Okay. You
don't trust men. So, you you tell them
to lower their gaze. Yet, you trust
their testimony. That's to teach men how
to behave. The western world doesn't
trust how how men should behave. So,
that's why they say lower your gaze. No,
no, no. It also tells the woman to lower
your gaze as well. But, it tells the men
first. What I'm saying is this. In this
in today's system, who's blamed more?
The man I mean the woman the men are not
trained to respect women. They're not. I
had to leave though. I have a train. No,
that's fine. But what I'm saying is
sister. Where's Piccadilly circus? Uh
there that way. Metro station. Uh that's
Lester Square. What are you getting?
Piccadilli line. Yeah, Lester Square
line. Uh yeah. Go Pik. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Read it. Have you read it
before? Yeah. No, I heard it. Give it.
Give it a chance. Look. Listen to me.
Come here again. What? What day is you
here? I don't believe in God. You do
believe in God. I just believe you
believe in God. You do. Don't look.
Don't be I respect people. Don't be
stubborn. You believe in God. Stubborn.
You are. You know God exists. I respect
you. I respect you. I respect that you
believe in God, but I don't believe in
God. Thank you for your offer, too. But
you did. We just talked about your eye.
It's made out of DNA. I don't believe
when I pray, all I see is four walls. I
don't see anything. Okay. So So you
don't believe Wi-Fi exist? You do you. I
respect you. I respect you guys. Do you
believe Wi-Fi exists? Huh? Wi-Fi? Do you
believe it exists or you say it doesn't
exist? Yeah, Wi-Fi does exist. How do
you know? Prove it.
Calculations, equations. What's that?
That's that's uh what's that? It exists.
But how? Allah has not Wi-Fi. No, I'm
saying you can't see. You believe that?
But we don't see. God, you don't believe
him. You have to be consistent. Yeah,
but but you can't plot anything. They're
like waves. No. How? Show me. I want to
test. I want to feel test. I don't have
Wi-Fi. No, I got Wi-Fi. Show me. Look, I
got Wi-Fi right now. My My hotspot My
hotspot My hotspot is connected to my
laptop. Show me. I want to see the way.
Just look up like whether Wi-Fi is real.
Wi-Fi is real. No. How's it real? Prove
it to me right now. Look, it's connected
to my phone. We can turn off and turn on
the Wi-Fi. It doesn't It doesn't prove
anything. Show Show me. It doesn't. Show
me. I need to leave. Okay. No problem.
Nice talking. We're here every Friday
and Sunday, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Please. I mean, again, like I I respect
you like It is. It is. But I I think I
think No, no, that's fine. But know that
you have a designer, someone's creative.
You didn't come from nothing. You You
know that very well. Opinion. This is my
opinion. It's my opinion. It's a
reality. No, it's not. So So you came
from nothing. So you came from nothing.
You came from nothing. I don't know. I
don't know. I'm agnostic. I don't know.
That's why I respect your That's fine.
Come come back. We're here for next
Friday. No, I'm not. Okay. All right.
All right. Take care. Take care. There's
one there. Well, that they escalated.